900 m² de bâtiments mise à prix
cent cinquante mille euros cette
ancienne école maternelle
la ville d'auxerre soit aujourd'hui s'en
séparer elle a donc décidé de la mettre
aux enchères conserver un bâtiment un
équipement qui d'habitude usages c'est
ridicule parce que ça coûte il faudrait
le faire fonctionner il faut drogba sur
et le chauffage et ça fait ce qu'on
appelle une friche en coeur de ville ce
qui est très déplorable une vente aux
enchères particulière puisqu'elle aura
lieu sur internet
elle sera accessible à tous reste
maintenant à trouver les acquéreurs
potentiels
le responsable du site a sa petite idée
il ya dans certains quartiers repris
pour faire une école privée
oui d'accord tekori par exemple donc
voilà il ya des projets qui arrivent
soit la question est désormais sur
toutes les lèvres
quel avenir pour ces bâtiments les
auxerrois ne manquent pas d'imagination
un petit supermarché un petit
supermarché puis bombe à quelques
logements on peut imaginer un lieu
artistique un lieu culturel
moi c'est ce que j'aimerais mais si
c'est commercial ben pourquoi pas du
moment que ça porte aux auxerrois
de son côté le maire d'auxerre là sur
les projets seront étudiés de près
imaginons que quelqu'un veuille propose
à 300 millions 400 mille aux aidants
fasse rien quel intérêt
je resterai avec une école indique ipa
bâtiment qui se réduit donc ce que je
veux c'est non seulement à prix
d'acquisition mais surtout à projets qui
accompagne ce prix d'acquisition est ce
qui permettra de faire un choix au mieux
des intérêts de la ville encore une fois
l'intérêt de la vie du coeur de la vente
aux enchères de l'école maternelle
débutera le 29 octobre
en cas de succès la ville d'auxerre
pourrait renouveler l'opération dans les
prochains mois pour se séparer d'une
autre école devenue elle aussi
encombrante